moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
les chiffres
c'est
[Musique]
voilà
ouais
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'il a
bush
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les ventes s
[Musique]
les problèmes
les secours
[Applaudissements]
merci oui ça fait ça fait plaisir de
revoir omar et fred comme ça ensemble
jacques joie à temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
est ce que tu peux pas nous faire le mec
en boîte de nuit à 6 heures du matin
quand il reste que lui sera possible
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le même temps qu'un vrai danseurs
ici si agen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
oh
ah ah
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces réseaux